I only have the starter mastermind which
gives me G Birkin I'm ready I don't know
G Birkin your Birkin keep working I got
a big eyes shoulder and a big juicy arm
can I be the Chad oh yeah I'm back just
like the male version of Chad from
Friday the 13th I guess we're just gonna
play downtown map because I don't know
what any of these are anyway okay I have
increased fist damage so get ready to
get fisted Oh
oh goodness and I have to select okay
there are decks of zombies that you can
unlock jerks no literally zero of these
things existed in the Sariel I don't
even know what we're supposed to do look
what is our objective here I love the
floor a lot apparently it's a friendly
fire no why did you test it on me cuz
you're you can handle it yeah how else
would you know because you're so strong
if you get infected you need blue worms
that's what I learned from the tutorial
okay waitis always if to pick things up
in this game it's unstable connection
with the mastermind hey friends
Bob you don't see anything yeah except
for my sweet ass yeah shoulder it yeah
so strong he's so big and strong okay
[Music]
I'm the best oh yeah now he's down okay
I'm gonna reload my stick that's it's
it's Bob in zombie form ah you got me
it's Bobby I went into my focus I never
Ram it
my tiny bones my sweet shoulders how I
not known for that wait don't trust that
you guys are really you guys are really
running through here don't worry Oh have
you guys seen a mr. raccoon it's a gun
turret shoot no no listen don't do that
when you shoot me it really shakes my
entire thing well that sucks
what you shoot Zig it shakes the camera
so badly I literally can't do a goddamn
thing
no I saved your life that was me saving
your life - I mean cause you know I
don't trust this puppy just can't what
puppy okay wait nice booty shorts thank
you thank you so you guys are not
picking up the things you should say
miss out the shorts who keeps doing this
someone's doing this look look look look
[Music]
it didn't hurt me at all okay so this is
the mr. raccoon what it's a zombie you
idiot it's treating thing on it
we drew things that you think there's a
traitor in this game like oh it's okay
guys I got the cameras fine can you stop
doing that no can you stop wait wait
come here I'm healing
also I grabbed a tail - a raccoon if we
find a raccoon got its
of course is a record there's a raccoon
right there okay you first
you first
Oh fire you know what I didn't I gotta
say it didn't oh yeah there's another
thing down here we need an arm will you
have an arm didn't you just say you had
an arm I have a tail oh okay I got it
boys don't even worry about it
nicely raccoon is all good just bounce
out take that Bob did you win win Oh way
area 100 my sensitivity just go up a
bajillion mouse sensitivity just go up a
trillion yeah what the hell okay it's
done you can pick up umbrella credits
and then buy stuff in that container I
think that's cool
also I don't know what she does I feel
like it was important to know what my G
button does oh yeah that's your unique
ability I think I have like a limited
ammo for a short time or something
uh-huh are you super punches huh take
that Karen look out he's got a gun maybe
I don't know set a gun Bob is that a gun
it's not a gun wait wait let me see if
it's a gun destroy the cameras what am I
supposed to do about it I need help I
can heal you well not yet never mind
go away I don't like you hey I see an
urban here Bob what's up friends how's
it going I don't think so
so I'm getting blues and yellows and I
wanna I want to count combini you wanna
oh it's still alive apparently I got a
security card if I must I don't I don't
understand these areas
well who are you at fram's you know
we're stuck in controlling a dbag
zombies at all in the slightest existed
out of this a whole [ __ ] slow kill me
what's happening out there
oh my god because I move one inch yeah I
do you got over there I walk into a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no Dommy Dommy Dommy Dommy oh yeah that
looks good how do you like them apples
hey waiting to speak can you not sir I
have no concept of Sledge hey listen you
need to let me put down my that's not
good that's that's not good guys behind
us
mmm that's not good don't think about
Bob you can't get me Bob I might be able
to see zoning yeah I guess what you
gonna eat TM what'd you get
how does an ATM how does an ATM help us
oh it's a rocket it dispenses money guys
explosive money what's is what that
sounds oh oh oh I think it's an
anti-tank like the fact that I kind of
got split off from everybody I want to
come back I don't know what the
objectives are
sizzling top left from American scream
oh no is that a gun
it's not it's just a camera you a-hole
no it's a gun camera it's good don't
trust him a gun brah a gum stupid look
out look out to the exit to the exit yes
oh my god
yeah let me oh oh oh can't kill us we're
healing get in my heal whole my whole is
unstoppable well that didn't really work
very well Bob you're amazing oh you guys
are all fully healed and I don't like
running out of resources here it's hard
it's my heel hole no one ever expects as
a whole
no there's a lot steeper of a learning
curve for the mastermind I'm not doing
anything
we gotta be way too sensitive right now
as well yeah oh my god what is with that
right and then it cams down what's love
bugs
got some good bugs on that I want to buy
something yeah don't don't buy stuff
that's not nice don't buy stuff can I
drop things how do I know I can okay get
rid of that herb smart huh what do we
eat them do you don't combine them
anything
yeah he dumb you dum-dum can you nerds
come out here what are you doing we're
getting ready for you we're getting all
big and beefy our big muscles we're
gonna get them all big for you we're
killing doggies the dogs chewy Bob my
sensitivity Solheim
oh yeah my 40 don't get a thingy on your
footing
he's got a gun gun camera okay good run
a gun brine it's fine it's fine can't
even control the camera when you do that
that's the zombie spawn you can't shoot
them when they're gold kinda shoot it
going doggy
yes golden poppy very simple science are
you mad boy I'm science boy hmm
suspicious
hey wait a minute
wave like a human being
shoot it that doesn't even make sense
hey wait doing that I've got got going
on in this game honestly it's zombies
guys where are you okay hey how you
doing how did you all just kid they just
died so fast we got guns
I nothing I could spawn does anything
except for my one ultimate douche bag
well it's it is running us out of ammo
so if you were worried about that
definitely what I'm worried about
okay Oh big boy big boy big boy oh
that's not good I'm gonna dispense money
at him with my ATM right right good idea
whip I'm stabbing this glass we're all
it's worth well that's not good no no
get that okay good trap haha I got him
I'm on ammo can I use this F yeah I'm
coming back up nerd
no no what no that's not love no I'm not
running I was walking very slowly away
so yeah are you actually kidding me my
guy's not doing anything
oh budget why I need more things do you
guys are gonna really enjoy being master
mob it seems real fun tell you what it's
so fun
I bet it's pretty fun oh that doesn't
what's the what's that sound
what is that the plant dudes the plant
dudes oh those are no good
no no bueno on those guys oh god I just
pulled one down no oh good god I
landmine
we should definitely use that that's a
good one to use all those plants suck oh
wow oh dog wait what well rude to the
dog I'm in the moment it's nothing
against the dog little rude
see everyone gangsters in the dog bison
in the ass that bit me in the neck
return the favor
ah what's going on I'm eating a yellow
herb I'm being eaten I'm the yellow huh
no I'll stop well that's not good we
need to destroy the course oh you're
right the core is the core but of course
wait you didn't finish off that one at
the top of the that one oh you guys are
so so Mickey Mouse we have seven left on
my sledgehammer I ducked
I got me super amazing don't go in there
goddamn yeah you keep punching him watch
him get the supplies on B punch yeah get
the supplies on me punch him I'm helping
okay punching him wait are you dead oh
that's a shame oh god Shawn god damn it
I don't know what that did that's not
good taking one of these that did that
not hurt him all right you're coming
with us
you think we're trapped with you he'll
never be stabbed in my ass like this no
you're not stabbed oh you're dead we run
away
[Music]
we got him I'll never suspect me
slipping by who missed me it was a lot
of there's a lot of zombies aha so are
you all the way did I respond one room
up first
yeah no however we only have a minute
left
so it did take time off oh well we
better get through this objective guys
yeah I would recommend the bio core sir
I need to be God I just got them by Oh
Boober wasn't one up here all the way
over there oh there oh it's Bob gonna
win no by pure random chance I'll shoot
oh my god it's so much health I got a
[ __ ] Magnum and it's not doing
anything
Charlotte - oh Lord
is this gonna be the third one got some
zombie friends no they're not our
friends
wait I see it on the map it's all the
way down and across its way it's on the
other side we're far from it hey Shaun
you just took ten seconds off what you
do though what you do Oh Shaun really
did it to us over time quick guys just
because my character is the one that
highlights the objective with my ability
doesn't mean they what that was a great
a performance apparently great I
absolutely owned you noobs what you were
doing towards the end there but it was
like never ending zombies yeah well I
sorta just had a huge stack of a lot of
zombies left and all the energy I could
use and just spam zombie right and right
around that place where you guys
strategy yeah I finally figured out how
to use one of the I think the most
powerful move of the darf G G Man G boy
that last time where you abuse on one
ultimate yeah that
that was the way yeah but then I stabbed
you in the butt and that that really
made you man really did stab me in the
butt what do we who's who's mastermind
now all right I'm gonna be Han you airy
girl squad in the haze ow yeah hell yeah
all right yes let's make it happen this
time we know what we're doing baby no no
you don't make anything happen
ba get it as fast as possible no wait I
don't know is your cursor is a face of
like a 12 year old unlike me I wanted my
character to finally have baby-faced if
you see what it would feel like because
it sucks have an old man face okay right
it's important to have a melee weapon
just to not waste ammo on things you can
avoid I think having one against those
things the insult yeah so should I buy a
torch I don't know what you can buy I
didn't have a torch there so you got
definitely mainly a weapon I see I think
as a torch I cuz our timer is oh it is
going oh god it is going okay wait no on
the ground we got hit the thing on the
ground okay yeah we're just trying to
completely objective so we got three
pieces of a puzzle
okay he's on me thank you
oh wait the master I know he's got a gun
yes
whoa sure do stop that my ammo
I'm putting the thing on the thing okay
so what does the puzzle piece look like
then it was a fox before this is a
different one so I don't know it's just
you gotta grab it and then you gotta go
get it
hit it damn it open baby hit it harder
harder alright there you go oh hey what
I just hear I heard something sound good
all you mean sound very infected there's
a lot of them going around
what do you do there's dago's there are
some dago's controller - he's got a
piece
kill him oh I can't see why can't I see
blind or something no no no don't laugh
he's got a gun
be in my heal circle he can't kill us in
my heal hole no I've got the piece I'm
gonna go go back and give the piece Wow
am I supposed to do now oh yeah surprise
army oh god no that's no guy what guy
guys no no no no no what are you talking
about guys we work together never mind I
don't need any of you don't come and
take my stuff I got it's my son's coming
back to help I don't like the laughing
on the girl I don't need to watch my
step oh god do not hit the mines Jesus
Christ you bang bang bang bang real good
I'm not helping guys it's all good
dogs right in front of us up nevermind
how he's got the gun again hang on I can
do something about this oh wow this
feels spammy whatever whatever I might
even care I'm putting a heel down it
seems to be a one shot oh god no oh god
no no no no no excuse me pardon me gotta
go sorry I gotta go I'm in busy
suspected you didn't know what you were
doing well you did resort to the
strategy that I ultimately want it for
me
so the strategy is spam everything yeah
puzzle rooms and just filled it with
enemies and that was it and then I got
Birkin and then kind of trapped you all
oh is that what you did because when I
got to the puzzle room and there was
enemies everywhere I was like what's
going on what the hell I was there I was
a real big mastermind it was a big brain
move oh I see well I'm glad I won cool
you should be my buddy you should be mad
now you guys man yeah I can tell you
want it
now I can tell you what I can tell you
why no needs to be called big brain it's
you but I can tell you want it you can
have it I'll get a next time do it I'm
beginning to think that it's really
unbalanced about the fourth player oh
all right way just go come on
but make it fast right after you my
friend I had to throw away this cupcake
wrapper look just do it not a bit
anymore now it's just really annoying
and boring you heard the man she do
gives Becca limited ammo for short
duration that sounds really overpowered
and also she's got sweet booty shorts oh
yes I see with Valerie yeah the heels
are really helpful helpful and the
identification of objectives seems
pretty nice I like it
plus she gives off like a Velma vibes
and I'm into that she's the girl next
door she does kind of look like Velma
you are right yeah girl squad girl squad
let's go oh sweet ass shot immediately
Wow yeah I'll just go let's let's do
this come on we got a hurry before
before Wade learns how to play before he
learns what to do search for the exit
come on that's what your thing does yeah
okay it restored the bingo puzzle where
- bingo puzzler or the bingo puzzle that
I don't know bingo board was a lock I
got a bell icon is that good
sure oh wait yeah we need a seven a bell
and a dollar
oh you wall up that dog I really want
him feel bad watching that meow thank
you thank you I might be able to see
something don't come to me okay but wait
don't even try don't even try wait don't
even think
don't even try you're trying your thing
in the door oh do we have them
where's over here oh he's so fast wait
what the hell he's fast that's fast this
to my house weights weights controlling
him but that's so fast
you said it moved like a slugger that's
quick I helped you a seven is there like
a specific place for a seven or do we
just get it yeah there's a seven hole a
seven hole got what the seven in the
seventh hole of seven no wait no no no
easy
I'm coming twitching can I like shoot
you guys or whatever no you got me I
don't know if you can shoot us watch out
there's a trap my trap card that's a
very very bright I'm gonna put a Hale
down just in case healing the key got
the key let's get out here you hit the
trap not helping you apparently shooters
good I'm trying
try takes that stinky I'm in caution
okay go through the door now oh wow good
job we did it dummy wave Oh sensitivity
that's such a strange but you're saying
now about this wait I can hack this
thing or something
no I can't don't Bobby you should
probably buy health I think you guys
should take your time just think about
what you're doing between you look at
this lovely velvet couch oh yeah we need
to hurry up cause he's doing things no
no
no he's not there's no way he's too
honorable for that defeat the security
guard zombie the security guard zombie
dude odds are they're in here I thought
we were safe yeah no there's no safe
route there's no safe rooms that's not
very safe no they're not they're dead
kill mr. blue he's got a gun camera oh
good job so fast miles an hour I can't
hit him there we go look out behind you
Bob you're going coming over here I'm
shooting mister oh my god I got one dog
I'm so speedy and my booty is amazing
how can I hit you oh that's not good Oh
God wait I'll save you you're not dead
you're not dead watch this amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
broken skull there that's my brain is
mush something to you guys
we respawn don't you worry I know and
I'm about to do number two of three nice
oh hi no no no no I get my wait listen
wait you don't want to do that cuz I'm
gonna bid see ya all right hey come back
you can't get me in here what's he doing
he's being a big dumb yeah I could see
your outline right --always daddy fell
over his good eye
it just says leave control mode
apparently that kills him yeah to
deactivate the security devices yeah
they're like little ATMs I did too I
don't know where they are
mark can you ping him I'm pinging as I
go trying to find things not really
finding the things you're talking about
whatever those might be I can't see the
last one oh I think things are going
really well right now
oh my god absolutely massacring dogs
right now that's awesome
where are you Bob I'm trying to find
online I just hit her in the crotch I'm
fine no come on you find it No Oh II did
I did I did I did yeah you've got I'm
tight voice run you into the next life
get out of here on the way it turns out
there's a bunch ah let me help
yeah you can oh yeah it's okay I don't
need you behind us oh that looks bad in
front of us oh [ __ ] you know watch out
in front of you your footsies all right
[Applause]
behind you toss I got a tennis shoe
Tammy - I'm getting bited don't get bite
at this time okay that's not good no
you're not not
my watch yes we can oh that's not good
that's what we call not good hey stop
shooting me hey anything can see okay
big gun for this one
take some enhancement spray everybody
your perfume course up top rows up top
guys Igor okay I'm using a sledgehammer
instead yeah good job Bob oh yeah I got
a swung in there your morale really
lifted my spirits gets logged good
absolutely pong Don douchebag yeah over
this way
yeah Oh dong for that hold on guys my
muscular shoulders all right go for it
ow my shoulders okay wait no throw blast
throw a grenade throw something you
can't kill me I'm healing my heal hole
is unstoppable
I'm fragile oh [ __ ] give my heal like
you hold my heal huh my heel hold my
heal old guys good lord
good lord guys you should keep flashback
or something I have flash bangs but I
can't throw them how do you throw them
right click and then throw guys come
back ok
there are more dogs out here oh we have
30 seconds shut up I'm trying
I really should use that ability I have
where I don't run out of bullets op
that'd be nice okay like I still wasted
all of your time we're one second away
from being leet ah damn it we said I
really took off that last second there
didn't I
damn it wait your records really wonky
being mastermind cuz like you guys go
through the different room so fast you
almost have to stack up like a room cuz
like we would load in and I'd be like
all right what do I have and I was like
put something in a room I look at the
map and you guys like alright we're
cleared three so it's like well I guess
I'm just loading up this last one then
yeah
so no it's monkey I don't think we're
supposed to take grenades and [ __ ] yeah
survivors feel a little weak overall but
maybe it's because we're the not damaged
characters or something I don't know
well and also there's not four of you
there's not mark that's how numbers work
okay so are we doing more we switching
experience the joy you're right okay
else experience yeah please demolish us
wish I had known some of the things I
know now and iowa's mastermind well you
wanna be mastermind again I guess I'll
be beck again no my back oh you could be
back at then yeah oh poor old face and
the booty shorts that say hell yeah I
don't like that sentence
alright we ready here we go Oh none of
us picked the healer [ __ ] that's ok
maybe that's the maybe that's the thing
maybe you don't need heals a lot oh oh
my god I've completely forgot how to
play oh yeah I have to clear the cameras
for the rooms Oh
yeah okay spooky guys this guy
oh that's bizarre oh this is weird yeah
it's a little wonk okay
why that guy died they shot him oh
you're in this room oh you're here oh
you're here hey guys how's it going
I did not shoot yet all right cool
good there with the shooting no not at
all to the lounge
we'll get there guys don't even worry
about it don't put those traps down no
no no what traps you don't always talk
about is that are you loving it okay
it's it's definitely wonk
it is definitely wonk wait it might pick
up - oh whoa whoa oh God
oh we enhanced him Oh God I didn't know
what I did do you ask it like I know
[Music]
okay I'm dead I'm dead gone to pieces
but oh did you put one in Bob
I put one in ya oh we have them okay
let's go back why doesn't it play
placing it with a and D for like moving
the camera is super weird yeah it's
pretty pretty jank
like for the exit' folks damn you guys
are quick you guys are real quick I'm a
dying behind is fine I'm doing all right
all right round two don't forget to
stock up on grenades and stuff okay why
would you blame this now what did I
blind it what did I do
you flashbang this I didn't know all
right
speed is key friends let's do this
muscular shoulders muscular shoulders do
it January
now I used my power now just swung a dog
out of the air
thank you so much this is fascinating I
will give it that it's very fascinating
if my fascinating do you mean all over
the place yeah all over the place very
all over the place very strange very
[ __ ] cool though so you can really
just throw [ __ ] zombies at people's
feet and take 15 seconds off I'm not
throwing zombies at you guys wherever
you are
I thought sounds bad Oh Oh interesting
we need to keep looking for the thingy
Oh big boy all right
Oh God fire bad
okay well I'll let you guys I don't want
a cornea that feels bad all right I
marry you come here what's the way you
gotta go here don't like it I don't like
it I'll get some of this nice good
you're learning you're learning I'm
proud of you
there I go you guys did it
proud of you oh my god he's spawning
things in by the exit I'm about to die
we're not supposed to be at the exit
I don't know he's spawning things in
over here I'm about to die oh yeah I'm
just gonna close that door you guys stay
in there that's fine in there things
again on my way baby the spawn point man
I gotta go how why does this year guys
what where you spawning things watch out
he's doing stuff he can do stone I was I
was revived in a crowd of seven zombies
well buried fine oh my God he's spawning
so many things I it's it's I think it's
completely imbalanced because after I
control the big guy you stockpile like
10 energy it feels like that's a really
unfair advantage watch out behind you
[Music]
sorry who's gone oh Jesus oh that's at
the room where's the room here's the
room I'm dead now oh that really burns
the time yeah see anything what the hell
is happening this is oh hold on hold on
please
you hacked me we just need to go to
terminal
I might be down down Jesus no no that's
definitely not true they're smart good I
feel great that oh that was area too
well we ready for another area sure I
feel like I feel like you did great on
that cuz I feel like I through so much
at you like unbelievable and I was like
this feels almost unfair but you guys
survived
very proud very proud okay destroy the
bio cores so it's over here next to me
and Bob
there are so many be careful Oh
landmines kill my own zombies that's
unfun he's there hello it's me I'm here
now no I didn't think now come here
right no no wait I think we need to keep
moving now I will do this nothing
apparently I will do nothing a single
one of these hit you okay 15 seconds Bob
you got this could be a lot less than
about now but man overtime baby here we
go oh my god Jesus that is so vicious
sure brain yeah this room gets obnoxious
without the fourth person yeah I could
definitely see how a fourth person is
necessary for that I would have to the
person is mastermind would have to be
going easy on you because I felt like
energy got up so much faster in the last
round too yeah the first area I was like
oh god they're gonna destroy me and then
like area two was like okay the third
area and you just yes yeah you guys flew
through the first area I wouldn't even
able to do anything but that last round
wolf yikes yeah big yikes you have to be
like super pinpoint targeted like get
the objective shoot it as fast possible
the exact one and then get there Bob do
you want strike you want treasure well
don't stop do something about it sure
I'm gonna be Tyrone because if the play
is to be aggressive and quick I think
it's like as much damage as possible
yeah you can boost our morale
then we fight better yeah let's give
this a try
by the way hacking the the cameras
really mess me up
yeah hacking it don't do that to me and
then like the disruptions very very
intense and then what I discovered is
like the gun is basically useless
because I'd rather just be placing some
biessings are named launcher at one
point that took Shawn down like
instantly if it was a one shot mmm yeah
that was a good shot I had one of those
but it was I accidentally pulled up on a
camera that you guys walked away from
before I could fire it so I just this
one's ready to go I didn't realize you
were just stuck as the anything here I'm
gonna save up let's just go for it let's
see what happens okay all right okay
Oh found it for you get kicked
dude I Terra's the best
tyrant is literally the best never be
stopped
why were you guys not playing Tyrone
that's good argument that that is a good
argument you know I got another one hey
Tyrone no mess no traps I've got peace
tired that trap put it in oh nice good
job Tyrone thank you look out
Tyrone swing Chuck Oh Oh God rally do
something
I'm gonna scream the power I'm ready to
fight I can't hit this guy what can I
not there we go
okay supply zombie we should always get
this guy always need help okay Tyrone
you're getting in my way you're kind of
behind you good thank you
Tyrone hits hard that's how your own
voice maybe yeah you sure about that
Tyrone hits good I just use your mind to
blow up your own zombie there it is
[Music]
there's stuff on the ground okay okay
there's dead end I think so there Tyra
oh oh wait no not dead end
wait Tyrone you strength yes
too strong broken Tyrone Power big hey
what's up so you want to be kicked
I love Tyrone so much I understand the
controls more now but I don't understand
how to win any better I don't think
energy in the first round again energy
is like non-existence Tyrone hurt a
little bit but Tyrone okay Tyrone get
sledgehammer I have a minigun what
thingies ah me give me a minigun so I'm
gonna use that one needed okay how I
stepped on a thing I'm an idiot
all right I gotta equip this oh god
don't shoot me dog standing under my gun
I wasn't more screaming what do we do
defeat the security guard zombie okay oh
god I never looked down oh my god I
kicked the hell out of that duck we what
are we looking for
security guards nothing over here
there's got to be a security guard
somewhere oh oh oh
Don yeah because my friends are DOM and
not here where are you
don't further popped Egyptian zone
that's Egyptian zone it's all Egyptian
zone
Oh pasty gyptian zone okay I didn't
understand your dialect by zombie dog
there's a lot of boobies I can't look
down Tyrone look forward always for it I
found the security guard zombie why did
that fall on my feet coming in for a
kick man he can't beat me I kick my arm
haha that's what you get alright MIDI
got the boss oh the kick works
haha come here and look nope hang on I
got you I got you I got you I got you I
got you I got you I got you I got you
get the keys the keys some of here you
got the kid
I can't do it I get kicked BAM
kick didn't work with the minigun would
you get out of here okay okay I want to
do things did he die
no not yet okay he will know well drop
the goddamn key off with kept objective
we have to do three things
yes I'm running but he's chasing yeah I
won't protect oh he's dead he's out he's
okay now be careful he's got like a
bajillion things oh not that counting it
oh that's a lot of dogs where a security
guard where security guard
we cut the security guard there's gonna
be two more okay well go get them then
you just run twice do I have it does
that mean I have it with hobbits oh oh I
could do it um that may be why not here
on the far right oh that's okay look for
a kick by missed no dude we get the love
where's the other one I think it's down
here if it's the same as last time
it's not the same as last time don't
look down
never look down the way we need to go
what do you mean everything is spawning
over oh that probably would yeah that
makes that if that checks out Tyron go
Tyrone going
Tyrone screaming Tyrone hurt Tyrone
round we're terminal meet Tyrone don't
understand technology it's here it's
here Tyrone kick kick Tyrone supplies
Tyrone use big supply
ah
Tyrone being bitten
Tyrone kid kicked Aaron dang oh my god
Tyrone dying Tyrone such a piece of gum
please need help no that zombies still
alive zombies still live John okay back
it down
[ __ ] I'm infected so I couldn't do
anything
Tyrone losing consciousness
wait it's not gonna waste our time even
if all
because we respawn Tyrone alive
Tyrone going to exit now he's barking Oh
for [ __ ] sake No
Tyrone might be in trouble Martin's
coming oh I see the wrong way Oh God the
exit screaming I was at the exit wait
was not at the exit what the hell
only one has to be at the exit we're
still not gonna win I was just keeping
you all away from the exit no I got
sensitivity honestly I've just wasted so
many resources on that you're probably
fine we only have 54 seconds okay let's
go let's go let's go
okay okay okay okay okay over here
you shoot it we get time if we break one
I think oh this is what Tyrone is for
okay it's right up here
yeah this one this next one yeah but
Tyrone handle this so many cards in that
one room you sure did you sure did
Tyron handle this set off the exploding
guys that was Sean no I said let Tyrone
handle this and then he didn't let
Tyrone handle this that's would've
handled he would have
[Music]